he and Whitlock speak for themselves
together every day on Fox Sports one fs1
and his new book yeah it's called never
shut up a starting available tomorrow
we're all books can be acquired man who
got Magic Johnson to Bruce Smith and
more to give testimonials to him on the
back of his book none other than
Marcellus Wiley hey riff
how are you Marcel all been great man
watching you now it's good to be here
with you right back at you when did we
first meet when you were on when you
were still playing right yeah on the NFL
Network I was a correspondent before
broadcasts right media and they had the
opportunity for players to be a part of
the media I just did it off of my own
relationships and that turned it to when
I was active player the years we didn't
make the playoffs
I would show up with this new network I
guess started his no four and a field
networking next he know I'm on a field
with LaDainian Tomlinson my former
teammate interviewing him because he's
in the playoffs and I'm a correspondent
that's how I started yeah I think we
started in no three actually we're
celebrating our fifth anniversary in a
couple weeks I think you were a cowboy
yeah for 2004 don't play off there no
you just come off of being with the
Chargers for three years yeah so you're
saying despite your success
well not despite your success in light
of your success Matt now Fox Sports one
and then all those years at ESPN the NFL
Network was the first one to knock on
Morse Ellis Wiley's door yeah how about
you given this a try hey you know what
give you your props for starting give
you your props because it's not easy to
do what you've done which is transition
from the NFL as you call yourself on
your book an NFL outlier yeah to go from
that to what you're doing right now yeah
it was really impressive Marcellus I got
to tell you it was a road less traveled
I'm obviously coming from the inner-city
Compton California South Central and
going across the country to Colombia a
place with such a great academic
reputation but not the yellow brick road
to the NFL a lot of naysayers along the
way a lot of people told me I wouldn't
make it or achieve my goals and then
taking there from Colombia one of the
lowliest programs at the time in terms
of reputation football wise and making
it to the NFL you
you're after are you the highest draftee
in the history of Columbia football no
they actually have had some first
rounders back in the 70s and you know ok
yesteryear times but yeah
second cuz I've done the combines in so
three I've never seen a Columbia anybody
run as fast as you do and that's why you
call yourself an NFL outline yeah it's
just the contradictions from one
destination to the next and not many
people travel to those same paths and
from that I gain kind of a different
perspective a fan experience it felt
like because I was living a dream so
through my ten year playing career I
kind of came into it a different mindset
did it seem like a lot of guys I wasn't
tired of big business football
I wasn't jaded from the experience I
really cherished every moment of it
because I was a guy who was told he
would never make it there in the first
place Marcellus Wiley here on the Rich
Eisen show and Drew Brees with his 500th
career touchdown pass and he went 501 he
went full on genes on us by adding
another one yesterday in a huge win for
the Saints over the Ravens and he just
here he is pushing 40 now getting out of
the pocket making some incredible throws
you were there when he first stepped off
the campus of Purdue yes and you were
there when he was a rookie in San Diego
did you see anything there when you saw
him that hey this could be a goat
walking into our mitts right now no I
will be candid to say no to the point
where Joe and I even had a little words
of difference at at times I was
empowered by the team his rookie year he
was struggling and people wanted Doug
Flutie to be our quarterback because he
was a veteran he has success in Buffalo
and Jews gonna be their future so let
Doug be the present and I'm one of the
guys that was told to go upstairs and
make sure that that change occurred kind
of in the Jalen Ramsey mode but I was
more outspoken then I think even Jalen
Ramsey and after one game I said seven
seven seven Doug Flutie should be our
quarterback who would have known that
true priests would make me eat those
words and obviously that message didn't
age well but he came in with his
positive and negative attributes people
said some people say that deadly
accurate not the arm strength you desire
for NFL quarterback
and I got to see him from throw one to
steal present-day seeing him do amazing
things what I love about him is the old
adage that football is a great game of
skill greater game of will when a guy
tears his shoulder off his body
basically when a guy responds from that
kind of adversity from his early playing
years that adversity he didn't hit the
ground running like LaDainian Tomlinson
did that same year to become who he is
right now all about character all by his
perseverance it's amazing I did not know
that story about you and Brees are you
and Brees okay yeah we're good we're
good
I don't know Brittany still his wife was
my friend the way it went down but you
know it was a different time there it
wasn't social media and everything but
no it's also to though I mean Big Ben
had that issue remember Alan Faneca is
like who is this kid coming in yeah you
know we don't need him right now we
can't turn things over to a rookie I
mean that happens in the NFL all the
time and I think the way that rookies
are now coming out of college now people
can't understand that that might have
been an issue for veterans with a rookie
quarterback who's drafted high now that
you see what my homes can do I mean
what's golf I mean Watson you could just
go on and on and on and now you're
saying why aren't these guys playing
right now as opposed to why are they
playing at all yeah I think we had a
different leash like our calendars have
to synchronize so if I'm a veteran I
don't have time to wait for you to get
good I don't have time for you to catch
up to us and come to speed with us and
we didn't have that leash for him as
well but obviously he proved us wrong
but different times there so levian
bells gonna be coming back soon one
would think did you have an issue with
what his offensive line said when you
first held out oh definitely
one I've never heard offensive line ever
come out and want to be on record names
faces to anything they're the anonymous
ones in the locker room they're the
smart guys they're the tightest knit
group they're the ones they want to stay
in the back in in terms of attention
because they do all the dirty work now
I've never seen a collective offensive
line just come out but that just showed
me how much desperation and love they
have for this player that they would
cross those lines to just show how much
they care for him you know it was kind
of
almost egoless like look we know we look
bad in this moment talking about this
guy's money offensive lineman usually
don't talk at all but if he's not gonna
come back
we're hurt by that and how kind of took
it from that perspective as well you're
the only one that's come across it's
taking it from that perspective yeah you
know I mean it's and we'll see what
happens as they're coming back against
the Browns who I mean Hugh Jackson
saying he wants to take the control of
the offense back a little bit more with
Todd Haley now going back to Pittsburgh
it seems like an odd time for him to do
something like that and Peter King is
gonna be joining us later on the show
we'll discuss that do we do you have the
overreaction Monday or reaction Monday
subjects for Marcellus and I to chew on
right are you ready to do this oh yeah
now we're not gonna be split screened or
anything like that okay it's just you
and I having a conversation all right
Rondo Chris Paul now before we get into
that you think Rondo won the
quote-unquote fight yeah of course what
of course please show your work back
that up what do you mean of course you
got the first punch off that's cool
that's how you grade fights in school
you know school times oh he hit me first
but punch first punch hardest but you
didn't push the hardest Chris got an
uppercut in there a straight right and
that's all after recovering from a first
glancing jab so I give the points to
Chris Paul you know of course now do you
think that Rondo spit on them yes
absolutely those accidents that are on
purpose
we're all guilty of it I've stepped on
quarterbacks fingers and when they say
man what you doing I'm like I gotta take
a step done' I didn't have to take a
step there Rondo didn't say anything out
of his mouth Rondo was not speaking to
Chris Paul he looks to the side if you
watch it then he looks at him gives a
little little look quick one even with
even with the mouth I've worn in my
entire life guess what I know how to
manipulate it
and did you look away it was telling
this one he didn't do anything else with
his mouth but one action that's telling
- hmm whenever you know you're about to
do something you always try to play it
off I mean this is his body language 101
man you can easily see the CSI will have
a field day with this is easy - easy
yeah Rondo spit on him CSI staples
coming soon CBS his most watched network
all right so I think that that was an
appropriate suspension from it from the
NBA - for cp3
three for Rondo and four for Brandon
Ingram who went top rope on this whole
thing yeah he did I mean Ingram deserved
the most because he he was the fire
starter tough phone Chris Paul you take
the high road one cuz you're Chris Paul
Players Association president hey I'm
not trying to get suspended off of some
altercation but you spit on me so now
it's like all bets are off but still I'm
respecting the consequences so what do
you do you must someone mission to
people who don't know what mission is it
means I want to hit you so bad but I
know I can't get it trouble this is mad
you want to miss your brother so I
wanted to just deck you so you must
don't ever come in my face again and
then Rondo being former rivals from say
oh the fights already started back and
now Chris Paul had to respect respect
that and responded that all bets are off
but school year our people would have
told Chris Paul once he spit on you just
swing but he took the hell because he
didn't so so this goes back 10 years did
you ever have somebody that you hated so
long when you were in the NFL but from
week one to week last you would have
moisture gone down throwing down or
anything Kennedy and I had our wars but
it was Lincoln yeah yeah yeah big
Lincoln like yeah thighs forearms yeah
the big ol arse is punched me every time
I was like man this hurts but the worst
thing is when I get a second Lincoln or
he pancakes me whatever happens people
are caught up in those moments it wasn't
those it was third quarter second is six
no one took note it's just another play
and he punches you and you don't get to
the quarterback
I mean the defibrillator when I'm like
all God and I got to go back this third
down and you just got to keep going back
to the head of security at the club
you're like this is the biggest dude I
ever met in my life and play out there
play Lincoln and I have some wars but we
can always smell it off at the end at
the end yeah you have to because this is
this with CP 3 and you know Rondo has
been bubbling forever and they're gonna
be you know they're gonna be playing
again and again and again yeah I mean
we'll look that's the nature of
basketball it will Fester it will bubble
because they don't have a way to really
let it out like Nick Lincoln and I was
like all right I see you on 3rd down bro
if you really got a problem and we can
handle that within the confines of the
game in basketball you get hit you get
two free throws but I still want to hit
you so it comes out and these little
antics in I got to hold on to the ball
from Rondo one year he did it Chris is
trying to grab it or I gotta hit you
with one of those every now and then
they can't really fully let it out yeah
that was really something and and
LeBrons evening that's what we were all
gonna be talking about beginning and and
the result that was gonna be happening
nobody but that was secondary yeah
absolutely secondary to what we saw a
lot of tug-of-war going on with LeBron
right now in the heart strange cp3 is my
boy Ronald's my teammate then the
reports of Rondo's girlfriend pushing CP
threes wife so now you got to deal with
that here that spilled out all it's real
in the field
yeah so now you got to deal with that
you got it next to LeBron wife Savannah
so Savannah has to talk to that go
through her emotions with LeBron
LeBron's to go through his teens
emotions because the optics don't look
good you're grabbing the other guy
instead of us and then you still gotta
deal with the fact that CB treats my boy
so how did he take this all but I think
Rondo's thorough enough to man up to
what he did wrong privately I don't know
if there's gonna be some big public
apology but I think behind closed doors
Rondo own up maybe we should get this as
a new episode of the shop right where
LeBron gets everybody in the shop and
let's hash it out you know it you know
let's get hash it we should get and get
Drake back oh yeah you know ambassador
he can John Stewart just just balance
well can we get let's just get him off
I would watch maverick Carter dared stir
it up tell a lie Manning let's just get
them instead Wow that's the show just
keep the Clippers out of the hands of
Brandon Ingram comes over the top
alright here's what I'd like to do I'd
like to take a break okay one more
segment with ya then we're gonna do the
overreaction reaction Monday so we get a
whole nice amount of time with you all
right and when Marcellus Wiley never
shut up is a new book that's out
tomorrow we'll discuss that a little bit
more with the co-host with speak for
yourself every day on fs1 with Jason
Whitlock Marcellus Wiley here on the
Rich Eisen show backward overreaction
Monday from the NFL and the rest of the
sports world in a moment hi welcome back
to the Rich Eisen show I'm just looking
through never shut up Marcellus Wally's
new book just look at his beautiful
family on the back right there I like
how you read you start in the back just
like me I know actually I'll be honest
you know I always look to see if
somebody's name is in the back you're a
mouse miss is more important to your
book what no just like you mentioned or
- six got your start so you've got a
little boy how old is he three three and
your daughter goes to UConn yeah she's
19 sophomore running track at UConn and
you've got another one on the way yeah
yeah I expect that in January
gratulations thank you now down you just
started it at deaf s1 right Yes respect
do you expect a baby gift from Whitlock
though I mean have you have you have you
are you tight enough with him yet we
respect we're cool
you know I think he already gave me my
first gift Casa Dragones if people are
not familiar with that tequila okay he
upgraded my tequila palate so I respect
that with Lux already done that yes he's
done that and he may ride that all the
way through the baby gifts a hanpan
I really took care of you in your
hydration situation but hopefully he
looks out for me but he's really another
gentle giant another guy that behind the
veil behind personna whatever people may
think of opinions is really a cool cat
who's always looking out for you
excellent yeah but skip is an ass though
right no
skip is the skip is the best actual item
oh yes I just took a shot that's keen
kind of LeBron is an Troy Aikman I just
took a show all right so let's do you
have do you have overreaction idea all
right here we go
reaction Monday Chris Brockman is gonna
read off a headline based on some of the
sports is it all NFL you mix it up here
yeah there's no it's not all NFL
okay so from this very busy sports
weekend he throws that a headline we
decide whether it's an overreaction or
not okay okay first up Chris go for it
they got smoked this weekend and he got
benched Blake bortles will not end the
season as the Jaguar starting
quarterback overreaction or not what do
you think overreaction yeah too much
money is invested in them you have to
give a guy a second chance in terms of
the benching how will you respond
because that's the true sign of your
character and how you deal with
adversity we all get knocked down is if
you get up and they won't give him a
chance to get up the only reason why he
wouldn't be the starting quarterback for
the Jaguars in week 17 is two reasons
one that he is injured two that they
have gone ahead and made a particularly
bold maneuver in the next week plus
because the trade deadline is next week
there's always that conversation about
Eli let's see if the if the Giants get
blown out tonight and fall to one and
six
I think bortles is gonna be the starting
quarterback on NFL Network with me and
they game day morning crew calling the
game against the Eagles by the way
that's a promo okay I think bordel
starts this week in London where he's
the Jerry Lewis of quarterbacks
everybody thinks he's the greatest
quarterback ever there because he he
balls out in London I think they're
gonna put him back in there this week
yeah but do not swap out a Blake bortles
for Eli Manning if I'm on that team I'm
like you just painted our problem
different but it's the same problem on
that's lipstick I mean no I know that
that basically bortles feet is what what
sometimes gets him through the day but
don't you think that Eli Manning would
would improve things over there
over borders
he doesn't even come in with the
reputation now that she would have to
respect the Revere player two player you
know we he's protected in New York a
two-time MVP and in that legacy but
right now I think enough of the guys on
the collective have talked about Eli
Manning say can't get you the ball man
shell-shocked in the pocket who can't
extend plays can't get off-script that's
today's in the Phil I don't think that
he will walk in and get the love and the
leash that he deserves that's an
overreaction from both this seat and
Marcella Smiley's what's next over there
Chris Philadelphia Eagles will miss the
playoffs I think that's an overreaction
definitely overreaction they're only two
games back in the division Washington
lead and they play Washington twice
going forward they do
yari one two head-to-head against Dallas
easy to spend that one if I'm in the
locker room and say hey we're fine we
just need to get this hangover behind us
let's get rolling what is the hangover
though right I mean cuz it was whatever
that is we saw it in the fourth quarter
they're up by they were up by 17 nothing
yeah and then here comes 21 17 they
couldn't stop cam who was just dynamite
in the fourth quarter that was a huge
win for Carolina yeah I mean every
hangover is different kinds of what you
had and if you look at this team what
they had was an underdog mentality
wearing the dog mask and no one respects
us and then the off season after you
become Super Bowl champions everyone
feel like they arrived everyone felt
like we're the ones now that's going out
there as the Predators they responded
better when they felt like they were to
pray and they start talking trash and
it's between the ears stuff you know
don't feel like you've arrived in NFL at
any moment especially when you're a
champion when you'll get everyone's best
all right what else do you have over
there Chris let's go to Minnesota Adam
Thielen is the best wide receiver in
football that's not an overreaction yeah
take that he's got he's he's tremendous
he is terrific the numbers back it up he
makes every catch he catches every throw
his way best receiver in football I'll
take it I mean not an overreaction
you're right but I wouldn't for my money
I still take a Julio Jones despite the
production issues at time and that's
more of a
Matt Ryan conversation de Julio Jones
Antonio Brown I still like him but
dealings right there so how about that
two years ago three years ago Dez Bryant
was right there it comes fast it could
go up fast go down fast but Thiel ins
Tier one with the other two guys so not
an overreactor but an argument but an
argument yeah don't put them at one okay
what do you have over there Chris Saints
are the second best team in the NFC
behind the Rams that's not an
overreaction I'll take it now obviously
this is gonna this is gonna be decided
next coming Sunday night when the Saints
and Vikings play one another I assume
that's the other team that you're
talking about Carolina could be thrown
in the mix you could throw maybe Green
Bay in the mix I wouldn't take
Washington over the Saints right now
look the Rams have to play someone I
think there's a cliff between them and
other teams whether it's saints or
Vikings but Vikings played them tough a
cliff huh yeah I think it is a cliff the
Rams are still semi mass unit the guys
have fallen left to right and some guys
are still trying to play through those
same injuries but note to leave still
Cooper Cup we don't know the extent of
his injuries Farrell Cooper a lot of
guys that they go and count on January
football haven't given them full effort
just yet because an injury their squad
by the way we're gonna find over the
next two weeks Saints next two games at
Minnesota home for the ramps yeah there
you go
see what happens a Tennessee man the
scheduling makers are gonna the Rams
will earn every last bit of it the Rams
take on minutes took on Minnesota beat
him already they're taking on Green Bay
at home this week they they were go at
New Orleans then they play Kansas City
in Mexico City we gotta call
Philadelphia at home I mean the only
team that's missing on this list is New
England pretty much yeah exactly and I
think that's how it's gonna play out AFC
NFC it looks like those are the two
teams to beat Chargers have something to
say about that as well Chris another one
over there please
this will be Jason Garrett's last season
as Cowboys head coach if they do not
make the playoffs we're both looking at
each other who's gonna go first I'll go
first it's not an overreaction
you think this is it if they don't make
the playoffs this year this this
division is ready to be taken
have a defense that is no joke Jaylon
Smith is ballin out vander Esch was a
terrific pick I know they a lot of folks
are like where's Ridley we need a wide
receiver van Dhiresh and that kid and
those front for that front four is no
joke also they've got Byron Jones on the
back end they are all they should be
able if they score three touchdowns if
they score 17 to 21 points they should
win more than not and you've got seat
back there
now it's dak suddenly so useless
sometimes it really is
I understand they don't have people
outside the numbers from time to time
that we can talk about but yeah yes
should win this division this year they
should and that's the conversation is it
is it the coach or is it that Prescott
that's the conversation for me it's
interested if you look at deck by the
numbers has never proved consistently
that he can be an elite quarterback
under these new rules a guy who's
mentally conservative doesn't pull the
trigger as Tony Romo kept pointing out
thankfully it's a little slower with the
eyes than you desire for an elite
quarterback missing some receivers that
are getting separation are open but I
wasn't that coachable I I would assume
so I would hope so but this is Dax third
year and he was thrown to the fire so
it's not like this is a young third-year
player this is a guy that you would
expect a little more out of to do things
on his own regardless of what's trying
to hold him back well you didn't make it
to FS one sitting on the fence is that
an overreaction or not Jason Garrett
stays beyond this year so overreaction
can you sneak one more in here Chris
yeah Michigan Wolverines are the best
team in the big town that's an
overreaction
Michigan is the best team the big time
not yet
Ohio State's come up with November 6th
it's the Penn State after after by
they're gonna kick the crap out of by
okay and then it comes Penn State then
they've got Indiana and Rutgers in some
form of a
one of the order and then Ohio State
yeah but they they have the ability to
be that they have the ability to be that
mmm your part ah been out there yet I
had not because I'm - I'm - you know
busy doing the the Sunday job yeah but
I'm pumped the last two weeks have been
particularly satisfying especially after
they try to write off hardball earlier
this year after the Notre Dame game it
you know it was coming
it is yeah this bond do you have one
last quick one yeah last one the Lakers
are owing to they will miss the playoffs
this year overreaction they're making
the playoffs still second best team in
the West once again that cliff is there
gold it would be so good
III think it's an overreaction they
missed the playoffs but it's not over
reaction this is about the second-best
team that was okay okay seas off to a
sluggish start no don't sleep on New
Orleans now New Orleans don't sleep on
Utah yeah
don't sleep on the Nuggets I give you
Utah out of that group but New Orleans
will find a way to implode Portland the
two teams that beat you all right yeah
good point that's true too
Marcellus Wiley catch him every day with
Whitlock on fs1 on speak for yourself
and go get this man's book please please
do man you bet please go get this man's
book never shut up Marcellus Wiley great
to see you hopefully this is not a
one-off I'm down love it man love
watching your success thank you.run
Congrats anytime you wanna race me 242
cuz that's what I'm about Benghazi suits
that's an overreaction yeah tear it up
in turf green huh okay top of our number
to the latest on college football the
top 25 list and why I think Alabama
should lose to LSU just lose it what am
I talking about see this man comes to
Memphis one a none hot taken like crazy
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience